i want to shout out a handful of people
we got this story from timcast.com
comedian jim brewer cancels shows at
theaters demanding proof of vaccination
the saturn saturday night live star jim
brewer cancelled his concerts well
concierge is a comedian at venues across
the u.s that require proof of
vaccination before entry becoming the
latest celebrity to protest vaccine
passports in cities like new york's
in new york
two quick updates on shows that you may
think you may be getting tickets to or
have already have tickets to the welmont
theater in new jersey not doing it also
the royal oak theater in michigan due to
the segregation of them forcing people
to show up with vaccinations i am also
not doing those shows out of the 54 year
old comic i know i'm going to sacrifice
a lot of money but i'm not going to be
enslaved to the system or money good
there's a lot of comedians that won't do
that there's a lot of performers who
won't do that there's a lot of people
who are just absolutely marching in line
with these mandates because well there's
money to be made so let's let's talk
about bravery so you're just mentioning
that you know people call you brave i
think what he's doing is brave yeah and
we'll talk about some of these other
communities in a second
but you were saying like oh come on i
just talk online and stuff right let's
be real though
in the event that you get canceled
meaning like your bank shuts you down
like hardcore like they've done some of
these people are you going to be able to
get a job at a regular place
wouldn't want one but yeah but actually
actually yes i would you think you'd be
able to i mean i i'm a very competent
person but it's not about competence
it's about being a pariah it's about
them being like look you know i i'm i'm
a fan but we can't deal with the
harassment antifa would show up see this
is this is further cowardice it's
cowardice at every level it's cowardice
at the employer level it's cowardice at
the employee level i agree it's k yeah
this is this is the thing so i i've said
before that cancel culture only works in
coordination with cowardice culture yes
yeah right if people were a bit more
bold and brave and willing to stand up
for themselves and stand by their
co-workers their colleagues their
employees what you know you're you're a
business owner
right you have you have you have people
who work for you right so if
one of your employees you know start if
people started messaging you saying oh
this guy who works for you know i don't
like his tweet or whatever you'll be
like
you probably won't respond but i guess
you'll be like what you'll you'll you'll
stand by your person and then they're
they're impotent they can't they can't
do anything else it's like okay i would
i would say
it's it's not so uh it's not so simple
most people might assume like oh we're
here great defenders that would never
you know uh fault would never falter in
the face of cancelled culture i mean
let's be real though like you can't go
and talk a carlson's show and say a
bunch of swears and racist things i use
him as an example because he's like the
biggest joke she's mainstream but he's
also a fairly counter culture yeah like
absolutely there are things that the
employees at my company could do that
i'd be like get out yeah of course but
not these bs micro aggressions none of
this this is what i'm saying right i
don't think anyone so
the term cancel culture sort of gets
misused a lot cancel culture doesn't
mean that anyone should be able to do
anything and there's never any
repercussions right right no that's not
that's not how society works if someone
goes on
so it goes on some huge like white
supremacist racist rant or something
right and then they get fired that's not
cancel culture okay but cancel culture
is
oh this person this person tweeted
something in 2011 and we've went and
we've dug it up oh he was he was 14 when
he tweeted it and now we're gonna like
come after him and people actually cave
to that or someone does something which
is not even
not even a transgression to any remotely
normal and reasonable person and then
they're you know a handful of twitter
people go after them or whatever and
people start people start caving so
there's certainly there's certainly
levels to it but so the reason i bring
up the job thing like if you do you
think you get a regular job i think
that i've already seen it we've already
seen with many people getting fired over
fear of like oh someone you got canceled
you were tweeting things you lose your
job so there are a lot of people that
are afraid to be public figures in that
regard sure like if i speak up i could
lose my job and so there is to a certain
degree bravery and being willing to be a
forward-facing political figure sure i i
i will never
get offered another job in establishment
media sure i worked for vice i worked
for abc news univision after that
company i got basically courted by a
bunch of the new york media
establishment and i ultimately decided
to do my own thing
that will never happen again yeah
because of the things i've covered
because of the things i've said
i actually had a conversation with one
of these high profile guys um a few
years ago after i had been running my
youtube channel for a little bit and i
saw him at the airport on the way to
davos of all places and he said to me
i'm not sure which side you're on yeah
and i said
telling the truth and then i asked him i
was like why won't you call it i pulled
up a specific story that was lies about
trump and i was like why don't you guys
correct this stuff why don't you guys
ever call out your colleagues in media
how can you just let it slide
so if you're willing to stand up and say
i'm going to lose money because i care
more about my convictions my principles
and believing this stuff there's a
certain bravery to it yeah but but i
will just say real uh also there's also
for me at least i don't i can't say the
same thing for you maybe you would agree
there's like kind of an obstinate uh
personality trait where i'm just like
you're not gonna tell me contrary it's
america yeah it's it's not necessarily
contrarian it's like if i just did it
you just you should have said that you
just couldn't write it it's a level it's
a little bit disagreeableness it's it's
not yes it's not about being contrarian
like contrarian and sense where it's
just like if you say something i'll
disagree with you if you're in the
majority i'll disagree no no no you just
have a disagreeable personality no no no
no no no i'm saying if i believe it if i
believe it i'm going to stand by it yeah
if i change my opinion i'll explain i
change my opinion on it but if everyone
in the country all of a sudden one day
starts saying vaccine mandates and i'm
like i disagree i don't care what the
ramifications are i'm not going to just
pretend to agree with it yeah one day in
the future you should re-watch this show
and when we're all telling you how
disagreeable you are and you're telling
us i'm not disagreeing with us it'll be
funny
yeah but that's that's that's like it's
a good trait for a lot of people
disagreeableness is a powerful thing i
know but but that's but but that's not
the point i'm making the principle like
the point i'm making is that
you i can agree with some if someone
comes in and they're like i think you
know everyone should have guns i agree
two years ago i didn't agree but i
changed my opinion after being convicted
and maybe you have conviction right the
point is there are a lot of people who
are perhaps agreeable or disagreeable
the point is it's not about being
disagreeable
like
i'm not going to argue with you for the
sake of arguing because i don't like you
that's tribalism where they're just like
biden should win because trump is bad
i'm like no biden should win if biden's
got good policies but by the way
when he's saying disagreeableness he
means like specifically as like the big
five personalities yeah yeah jordan
peterson okay yeah yeah so like just
yeah being able to stick up for yourself
and being
willing not to just always go with the
herd because this is the thing like
human beings we we are individuals and i
think society sort of sort of feeds us
this line in the west that everyone's
really really individual and unique and
special but the truth is
we're also hurt animals and the majority
of people always want to be
in the majority you are going back and
talking about would somebody have fought
against slavery or fought against the
nazis etc the reason why those things
were so difficult is because
most people
want to be in the majority to to go
against the majority on anything
is potentially risky and scary and you
can understand that because we're
hardwired to be in tribes so
risking any form of social ostracization
could have been deadly in the past now
it's not so much deadly but there's
still potential real
repercussions of that and it's that that
people fear it's not that they
are afraid to speak in itself it's just
simply that concern what what are other
people going to think right let's talk
about these comedians so uh you know i
highlight jim brewer and he's fantastic
he's had very anti-woke bits i think it
was jim brewer this bit about his
daughter going to college and hating him
he's he's great patriarchy patriarchy
yes yes
awesome
well so he's like i'm not gonna do the
shows yeah pat and oswalt oh did the
other the opposite he told the the the
venues that you have to and they said no
so he was like well then i'm pulling out
well then we have the in between you
have joe rogan and you have tim dillon
and i got into uh twitter you know
twitter back and forth with tim dillon
on this one hot tim on tim action yeah
so so tim dillon
on his podcast his latest episode is him
being critical of the federal vaccine
mandates okay he even criticized it on
twitter but then said i'm not gonna
cancel my shows to the event these
events simply because i disagree i
wouldn't cancel my shows in texas over
the abortion bill passing
to me that's an excuse
joe rogan is going to be performing at
madison square garden he's already sold
13 000 tickets
he booked that before the vaccine
mandate now he's offering refunds
i i don't know the circumstances for joe
maybe he's got a very serious and
massive contract and there's a serious
liability for him bailing and canceling
on the show so offering refunds is
probably a good thing but i'll still say
based on the information i have i don't
understand why joe wouldn't cancel that
if he's gonna come out and say the
vaccine mandates are bad if he's gonna
you know go to the doctor and get
prescribed these you know alternative
treatments or whatever and not be
vaccinated wouldn't you then say i will
not support the system that is forcing
regular people to get the vaccine like
even if you in new york city the vaccine
mandate there's an exemption for
performers
if you're a celebrity you don't got to
get vaccinated okay if you're a
low-level guitar player playing at a bar
you also don't get vaccinated so
you know what i was i saw tim dillon
tweeting about this saying that like
he he he called his fans brain dead he
said for my for my more brain dead fans
i'm not the one mandating anything it's
the venues and the the the ticket sales
people and the governors blame them and
i'm just like
first of all like why you're calling
people brain dead for
for saying yeah i mean i get it maybe
that's his style or whatever but i'm
like he's already made this thing kind
of he's already coming at people because
they were tweeting at him saying like yo
why are you playing these venues let's
be real in new york city with the
mandate you can drive a half an hour
upstate find a better venue with no
mandate you can cross the river and find
a venue with no mandate if you want to
perform in these places you're choosing
to do so
it sounds to me like he's just making
excuses for wanting to perform at bigger
venues that make him good money and
that's fine but then i i i i just see a
guy who's going to come out and take the
position of yeah vaccine maintenance are
bad why yeah well he got ratioed uh to i
think his fan stepped in and then the
race going back and forth but you've got
people saying like he's being called a
sellout now
whatever call him whatever you want to
call him i just think that if if i were
to go on a show like this one like
vaccine mandates are bad
you would not catch me dead putting on
an event with a vaccine mandate just
like
even if i didn't believe it you know why
would i ever subject myself no no but
the reality is we're not going to do it
we are putting on an event the tentative
date is october uh well late october
october 22nd is our october 23rd sorry
and then uh no vaccine mandates it's
gonna be in west virginia open no masks
whatever because i wouldn't do it
otherwise yeah but i look at some of
these people
and it kind of bums me out that jim
brewer is i don't think he's
he's probably wealthy i mean he was an
snl he's a famous guy
half-baked yeah for sure he's a funny
guy he's a great man so
he's he's probably wealthy to a certain
degree i'm not gonna pretend like he's
the one percent you know joe rogan's
estimated net worth is in the tens or
hundreds of millions or whatever yeah
but
how much is enough that you're gonna be
like you know what
i don't need to make another 10 grand
performing at this venue that's going to
subject my fans who are upset about well
at this stage with hyperinflation
nothing you could never maybe possibly a
sandwich could cost a hundred thousand
dollars so yeah but come on it comes to
community i mean this is legit social
currency is where we're going sure ian
you get paid 10 grand you put it in
crypto you put it in property you don't
lose the value because of hyperinflation
if the banks knock your bank account out
you lose it like and the property is
there with your name on the no amount of
money is going to ever be enough that's
the point it's people you need people
you know you need you need society you
need culture and
friendship i understand that for some
people no amount of money is enough and
that's what i can't understand
because i got to tell you you have to
survive like 30 000 a year i think the
the 10 years ago it was considered 77k
so look at inflation i'd say you'd have
to double it at this point maybe maybe
125 in new york it's like 200k a year
but i just don't get it you know look
200k a year sorry that's that's for what
specifically like to be considered
perfectly middle-class vacation you have
clothes you go to the dentist you have
healthcare i just i just can't
understand as high as 200k just to be
considered middle class in new york city
yeah so in new york city 10 years ago it
was 150.
a thousand per year to be considered
middle class that's okay i didn't know
it was that high for the rest of the
country it was 77 so it fluctuates with
cost of living i just here's what i
don't get and and it could be very
simply that joe rogan has a contract
with madison square garden that is
probably massive we're not talking about
a little rinky-dink club here he could
be on the hook if he severs the contract
for like millions of dollars or whatever
but i'm just wondering like when you do
a 100 million dollar deal with spotify
and you were already making tens of
millions of dollars he's not gonna get
more i mean he can get more rich but
like what do you do with the money and
he's not gonna get more famous so at a
certain point couldn't you just be like
i mean actually i'll tell you this with
on lex friedman's podcast joe rogan said
he had fu money yeah and that he just
buy sports cars because well if you got
the money and you know that's what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
be okay well then stand up for your
principal say no to the vaccine mandate
and tell madison square garden you
change the term of the terms of the
contract by mandating this i won't
perform yeah what does he need from them
it bumps me up i don't know man i mean i
feel like anything i would say on that
would be
would be speculation you know we've both
been on on joe's show multiple times we
know we've met him most people haven't
and i don't know i mean i know what i
would do in that situation with the
information that i know as you alluded
to there could be something in there
in a contract which
is really putting in between a rock and
a hard place i don't know so i'm kind of
hesitate to hesitate to speculate on
that i do think though that in terms of
the in terms of the general
wider principle
then
i i do actually think it's extraordinary
extraordinarily important for high level
musicians comedians performers and so on
to
uh actually to boycott this
if if they do
look some people don't just real quick i
want to say the same thing for tim
dillon too like he booked his tour he
may be like i can't pull out of these
contracts so you know with respect that
could be the circumstances i mean i know
artists who are on um you know artists
who are on a much much smaller level who
have cancelled entire tours because of
this
so again i don't know all of the details
and these these are guys who you know
need the money
far more than someone who's already
worth a hundred million dollars plus and
they've pulled out on principle and said
you know what
i i'm not going to perform in any of i i
i i announced that back in
back in april or so
before there was even so much talk let
alone implementation of these vaccine
passwords i said look i'm not going to
perform at any venue where people cannot
enter
unless they they show their papers
proven i was like it's never been like
that before
i don't want it to be like that in the
future i'm not the biggest artist in the
world like i'm not gonna crush the music
industry by me doing that
but that's that's my line i think that's
my line i'm not comfortable tying it
with what you were saying earlier about
how we're we're individual but we're
also hurt animals this is the point when
one very famous person makes that call
and decides i'm not planned people
follow that is how we're coded they do
and look
most people most people are against the
mandate
if you go to cnn they say 51 are in
favor nonsense nonsense most people are
against the mandate i think so too most
people are against the mandate whether
people have had the shot i know there's
people who are super pro-vex who
literally think almost everyone should
get it but they're like but
no it shouldn't be mandated because that
backfired yeah
but not just that it's just
fundamentally
it's look if the government can force
you to inject something even if you
believe that that thing is is good for
you right the government shouldn't be
able to you know vitamins are good for
you the government shouldn't be able to
enforce you to inject vitamins exercise
is good for you i'm a huge proponent of
exercise i'm a huge proponent of healthy
eating the government should not be able
to force you to go to the gym or to lift
weights or to go for a run all right so
you can be very much in favor of
something yet totally opposed to it
being mandated on on a state level or
even on a massive corporate level look
at the people who supported michael
bloomberg voted for him in new york this
is a guy who says tax the poor you ever
hear you ever hear a speech on this he's
like speaking at an event i don't think
i heard new york and he's like you got
to tax the poor
because they're not smart enough to buy
the things they need so if we take their
money from them we can give them what
they need so so he did the drink tax
okay or he tried to do the drink tax i
don't know if it actually he pulled it
off but he was like
oh you know large sodas will be taxed at
a higher rate okay yeah trying to deter
poor people that's what they do they do
punitive taxes we'll just tax the
cigarettes make it harder for them to
get them because they're bad for you
government shouldn't have anything to do
with that i will say
there's a line uh schools and certain
public uh facilities
uh institutions do require vaccination
like your standard you know mmr i think
that's unique to the usa by the way
really maybe not totally unique i don't
i i don't think that's the case so in
much of europe there's that there's that
argument where you know chris wallace of
fox was like ragging on the the governor
of nebraska i was like well what about
all these other vaccines you know but
well i'll just say really simply yes
over years of research with long-term
studies we sat down and had a
legislative body determine that we
should have certain requirements for
vaccines that are readily available and
considered safe and uh well there you go
that's very different from an emergency
use authorization edict coming from a
governor who didn't pass the law through
notice no conversation no debate you
know there should be an opportunity for
hearings there should be an opportunity
for representation
i'm not going to sit back as joe biden
circumvents the two other branches
there's something really interesting
that you perhaps inadvertently
highlighted there which is the concept
of precedent
and that's the one that's the worst
thing that's come out of the past 18
months is the precedents that have been
set right so i don't think that so even
if there are other
it sounds like here in the u.s there are
other vaccine mandates for people to go
to certain schools or i think to be in
the mail like i actually oppose that
right so just because
they've made that decision in the past
and set that precedent
to me that doesn't mean
okay that this one's okay i'm like well
i don't think that was i don't think
that's right either
um and what we've what's happened now is
precedents have been set for lockdowns
precedent has have been set for
stay-at-home orders for forced closures
of businesses for forced forcing people
i mean bro i grew up in saudi arabia
i remember just two years ago what was
the thing that people always oh that's
horrible they they make women cover
their faces
right
all of a sudden you know in france in
germany in the uk they're they're
debating back in 2015 2016 should we ban
the burqa should we ban the islamic face
fails whatever now you're mandating the
burqa and you're just calling it science
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you